it actually [__] happened fortnite is
dead
fortnite is done
with the building the core idea of the
game since it blew up in 2017 building
will be removed
at least for now and it's getting a lot
of love from fortnite veterans players
like ninja and tim the tatman are all
giving the change their stamp of
approval while some players like tfu are
asking for the change to become
permanent dang even doc a long time
hater of the game likes the new change
now whether or not it's here to stay is
anyone's guess many are hopeful this
will bring back the glory days of the
game before kids built taj mahals
anytime they got hit and zoomers got
cracked at cranking 90s now will this
attract more players than adding dwayne
the rock johnson to the game only time
will tell in the meantime pour out your
g fuels for cranking 90s
it just seems like a waste